people are searching for families in
Emergency Shelters and search teams are
scouring debris to look for human
remains to begin the process of
identifying bodies thousands of people
have lost their homes and livelihoods
the historic town of Lahaina is all but
destroyed residents say they are coping
with unimaginable loss
it's been so hot
very hard
never
I think in my year
in my life what I have imagined that we
would have something like this a
catastrophe of
an unequal disaster
questions are being raised about why
Sirens weren't activated on the island
when the fires broke out or she had
returns he reports from Maui
Saturday was the first time cadaver dogs
were used to search through the ashes
and Rubble of Lahaina in search of human
remains buildings were marked with a
bright orange x when they were searched
and with the letters HR when human
remains were found the police chief said
it was a slow process
that's what's been searched with the
dogs three percent
we got 12 more dogs on the way today we
just made that I made that request FEMA
made that happen they're on their way
but think about how hot and how humid it
is and we can only go as fast as that
animal can go
so we're bringing in more once again
officials deflected questions on whether
more could have been done to prepare for
such a ferocious fire and whether
warning should have been issued before
the Flames engulfed the town there's a
lot of energy you can spend on this
tragedy right now I think that time
should be spent on recovery and
rebuilding but it's now clear that
reports have been issued since 2014
specifically about lahaina's increasing
vulnerability to wildfires not only that
authorities were alerted in 2020 about
the possibility of the Winds associated
with a hurricane located hundreds of
kilometers away from Hawaii acting as a
catalyst for fire here
for a second day plans to allow
residents of Lahaina back in to assess
the damage for themselves were subject
to changes and confusion these are I
belongings this is what we were able to
grab behind a resident skip Scott said
extra restrictions were imposed after
some of those who'd made it back on
Friday had entered devastated areas that
authorities had cordoned off desperate
to see what was left there are a lot of
residents they just wanted to see if
their house was still standing and just
to assess
you know what they're going to do next I
mean a lot of us are trying to make
tough decisions and whether or not your
your house is still standing or not is
is a big factor in that but it's these
areas that are thought to contain yet
more dead and still over a thousand
residents remain missing she ever can
see Al Jazeera Maui
David Bowman is a professor of
pyrogeography at the University of
Tasmania and he explains why the fire
has been so devastating
it was bad because of a whole
constellation of factors
extreme weather drought
unmanaged grass fuels and inappropriate
uh
sort of Urban Design I suppose
and a Reliance on mass evacuation and
these things escalate so quickly
it's terrifying scenario when you have
people literally
diving into the ocean to save their
lives that that's that's not that's not
acceptable that's that's not adaptive
the things of famous idea of what's
called a grass fire cycle and Hawaii is
the icon of that where you introduce
grasses from tropical regions very
robust grasses and they have no
herbivores native herbivores to eat them
so you have this extraordinary biomass
of grass fuels and then you get a
drought and basically you've got
effectively it's like saturating a
landscape in petrol and all you need is
a spark and a strong wind and you cannot
outrun this fire and that's why we're
suspecting that so many people will have
died because they didn't have a chance